[موسيقى]
كنت في الحكومة لمدة 15 عامًا ، وفي
معظم ذلك الوقت كان لدي على الأقل
تصريح سري للغاية لذا يمكنني أن أخبرك
أنه من الأسهل مما تعتقد أن
تنتهي المعلومات الحساسة عن غير قصد في مواقع غير آمنة
المصطلح الرسمي لذلك يسمى الانسكاب ،
فكر في كل مستند سري
كقطرة ماء في هذا الكوب بينما
يظلون في الكوب الآمن الذي
يحميه ما يقرب من 3 ملايين شخص
بمستوى معين من التصاريح الأمنية
التي يمكنهم الوصول إليها ولكن  هناك
الكثير من المواد المصنفة هناك
نتحدث عن مئات الملايين من
الصفحات والكثير من هذه المستندات في حين أنها
مصنفة تقنيًا ليست حساسة بما
يكفي لتكون تحت القفل والمفتاح طوال
الوقت حتى اليوم ، لا يزال الكثير منها
مجرد  أوراق ورقية وفوق ذلك
هناك أكثر من 2000
دليل تصنيف سجل عبر
الحكومة الفيدرالية ، وبينما يضع القانون
إرشادات لأمن الوثائق ، فإن
الوكالات المختلفة وإدارات البيت الأبيض المختلفة
لديها
مجموعاتها الخاصة من القواعد أو القواعد للتعامل مع
المواد الحساسة  وأحيانًا يتم
ارتكاب أخطاء وعندما
تبدأ الأمور في الفوضى في كثير من الأحيان ، يكون
خطأ بشريًا بسيطًا ، حيث
يأخذ مسؤول عن طريق الخطأ إلى المنزل
مستندًا سريًا كان يجلس أسفل مستند
سري أو يتم
ترك ملف عن طريق الخطأ على مكتب شخص ما الآن إذا كان هناك شخص ما
ينوي الاستيلاء أو إساءة التعامل  المستندات
التي هي قصة أخرى تمامًا ،
وتتدخل وزارة العدل التي اعتدت أن أعمل فيها ، لكن معظم حالات
الانسكاب لا تؤدي حتى إلى
تحقيق جنائي تم حله من خلال
محادثة بسيطة مع
ضابط أمن بالوكالة بعض منتقدي الوضع
الحالي  يقول النظام أنه يجب علينا تصنيف عدد
أقل من المواد ، ولكن حتى
نتعامل مع جميع المواد الحساسة
الموجودة بالفعل ، يمكننا أن نتوقع
استمرار تسرب المستندات السرية